[Music]
carrie is in athens
georgia hi carrie welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave how are you great how can i help
i have a quick question um back in march
um uh we decided you know the stock
market was looking very very bad
and um we've always just saved all of
our our money
into our 401k for retirement
but we decided at this moment because
between the market going down so much
and
my my husband had lost his parents
it was just one of those very scary
times and so he took a bulk of our money
and put it no into cash
and so of course yeah so it's in cash
so he took a huge loss
he sold at the bottom yeah
yeah oh i'm sorry yeah yeah so how much
cash have we got
well left in the market we have about
350.
and how much cash cashed
he said he took it out in cash he cashed
it out right
well i he moved it to cash okay inside
is 401k
yeah so there's 350 in the market
meaning still invested in mutual funds
and the other
is in cash and how much is in cash
um 900. oh god
yeah okay and so of course he expected
and it was you know at the time like i
said it was not something he would
normally do
i think it was a very emotional time
because he lost his parents like i said
um and so now um
you know he just how old are you
we're in our early 50s okay so what's
your question
so the question is okay so do we
because i do know we know a little bit
about real estate and i have
one home that's paid off um and one has
a mortgage
do we take the bulk of that now
that at 900 and just start buying more
investment property if you're taking out
of your 401k you're going to be taxed
and penalized
yeah you're going to give up 40 more
you're going to give half of it to the
government
okay i didn't think it was that much
well i mean it's
30 tax rate plus a 10 penalty
right so another 400 grand is gone
i don't know i can't do that yeah yeah
that won't work
yeah and and and carrie here's one of
the things that happens
people get very like you said emotional
uh you start losing loved ones and
things start you you you hurt um but
but i'm i'm gonna advise you all to that
stop
gap to have in there is to have a
professional to talk to
so you don't make the knee-jerk reaction
so investment professional an investment
professional a counselor you
you all need to be able to have someone
that you can sit and bounce ideas off of
and be given information back that truly
will help you
like not only do you all need an
investment professional you need a tax
professional now
uh to really start to look and
understand the estimated tax you're
going to have in
income april no they're not going to
have it it's still in the 401k you said
right no
correct you have cashed it out just move
the money from mutual funds into cash
inside the 401k yeah yeah that's what i
thought
okay i misunderstood okay yeah so
you know it's a pretty simple thing
you're only 50. um
you've got another 15 or 20 years to
invest you made a mistake that cost you
probably three or four hundred thousand
dollars
correct correct and so i'm just going to
start investing
you need to move it out of cash into
mutual funds today
oh okay and just because what do you
think the
american economy is going to do in the
next 20 years regardless of democrats or
republicans
i have seen it grow in every single
20-year period
in modern day history
okay okay and so you got 20 years for
you're going to need the money i'm sorry
what about bonds though is i know that's
safe
no they're not okay no they're not you
know what happens to bonds when interest
rates go up
what's that bond prices go down they
have an inverse relationship with
interest rates where are interest rates
in comparison to the last 30 years
they're at rock bottom lows where are
they going to go from here
eventually up bond market is the
absolute worst
place to be right now okay
so here's what you guys need you've got
to have to retrain your brains
you need to go what happened was you
made a
really bad decision
really bad and you need to undo that
decision
and you need data points
and historical data on mutual funds
that indicate to you that you made a
really bad decision
so that you don't do it again and that
will also give you confidence to invest
going forward
which you don't have because you just
told me you wanted to do bonds
right so you guys do whatever you want
to do if i were you i would sit down
with a pro what chris is telling you go
to daveramsey.com click on smart vester
and don't go over there to invest go
over there to learn
for a little while let's just gather up
some learnings
yeah and just go and let them just teach
you without
shaming you i'm not trying to shame you
but i'm trying to
but i am trying to convict you because
the the
conviction versus condemnation because
when i do something that's dumb and it
costs me money
and then i i have to have confidence in
the future
to not do the same thing or not stay on
the same track
and so what you're telling me by asking
me about bonds is you still don't trust
the stock market
over the next 20 years and i do and by
the way it's the only reasonable option
for your 900k right now because it's
inside
of a 401k and so put it in mutual funds
let it grow again and you just you just
and don't obsess like glance but don't
obsess over it like like it's
it's remember investing is long-term
it's gonna be the roller coaster ride
you're gonna have the ups and downs but
i mean you can we can look inside of
this year with a pandemic at what the
market has done
and what it's doing right now and what
it's going to continue to do so
slow down kerry like dave said you need
to get somebody in your corner to guide
you
that you guys can sit and look at this
and go oh
this is how it works and this is the
expectation of what's to come next
and you'll get confident and you and
your husband will be able to breathe you
all have done an excellent job
of having money invested you've
intentionally put that money away
so i'm proud of what you've done now
let's get back on the
course back into the game so we can
cross that finish line young lady